we're talking late 70s over to early 80s
a crucial period actually for
computers in many regards yes there was
definitely a british's best britain
first
purchasing policy either for government
institutions like
radar establishments like the police all
this kind of stuff
and particularly for educational uh
establishments
the feeling was computers are expensive
so
if we can spend a lot of money it might
as well be fed back
into the british economy by buying
british
certainly applied to universities one or
two were allowed to escape i think
university of newcastle on the computer
science front
was allowed to have an ibm so of course
was the university of cambridge i can't
remember what happened at oxford
it was a way for me to find out by the
back door
about the advantages in a way of
sharing a hardware platform with
not just other universities but other
government institutions
and in one of the previous videos i've
talked about how we only felt
able to use algol 68 as a teaching
language
because that well-known government
institution blessed them the royal
radar establishment had actually put a
huge amount of effort
into setting up a very good algol 68
compiler
and of course it had to be on ico
machinery they were a government
establishment
so were we so we benefited from that a
lot
how did you get into unix you went to
the states didn't you can you tell me
about it yes i
it's true i went over to the states in
1978 for the whole calendar year
and visited in short order and it was
all highly educational
a visit to oklahoma state university
where they'd written an alcohol
68 compiler so given my interest in
those days that was a no-brainer but i
then thought no no if i'm going to be
away for a year
i want the california experience
and so i finagled my way into doing some
teaching
at ucla of course in los angeles but
also
in the cal state system cal state
northridge is a well-known
california state thing and i did i
lectured all sorts of computer things
there
taught fortran in oklahoma and so on
it was weird actually but in some ways
at nottingham we were a little bit ahead
of the curve there
because before i left we've taken our
first tentative steps
into getting this thing called unix
which enabled you
on a underpowered pdp-11 to sort of run
your own
programming experience multi-user but
only on dumb terminals
yeah multi-user multitasking operating
system
hopelessly under bad machinery but it
sort of worked and this was
must have been about 76 when we bought
um
first of all the pdp 1105 just to get
used to having our own computer
of some sort could do a similar
programming but i think just more or
less as i
got in the plane for america colleagues
told me that no
we're going to get that upgraded to a
pdp 1135 as quickly as possible
and that when we do we will be ready
to receive this
operating system called unix done by
bell labs
and people said to me today if you'll
find just like
why did a radar establishment have to
support your
compiler you'll now be saying why does a
telephone company
have to be the people that provides me
with a little operating system that i
feel happy with
and uh it was it was as yogi bera once
said
like deja vu all over again oklahoma
state they were saying wow you know
you're ahead of us we want to go to
eunuchs we can't get approval all this
kind of stuff
so when i came back uh 1979
very cold winter all that it really was
a liberation to know that
while we might have to rely on the
competing center for a lot of
bulk teaching and running programs
nevertheless we could start to do
our own thing on pdp-11s
with an eye to the future but even so we
couldn't
on a peter 11 35 give a bulk service
to our compsci undergrads we continued
running
algol 68 on
icl machinery with a huge extended
overlap with us getting
eunuchs because we couldn't become
self-hosting on units or have
enough big powerful machines until well
after this era we were made very aware
that we were getting this for a few
hundred dollars because it came from
bell labs
bell labs was a so-called regulated
monopoly
and that meant they were caught in the
crossfire from everywhere
they must not be seen to be using their
massive leverage and obscene telephone
bills
to squash little startup telcos
they must not get in the way of ibm
because there was a suspicion that you
know
when people said to bell i was well what
are you doing for the public good
they thought it was a nice cool idea to
say look we've got
basically a computer science research
department we're not a computer company
but these researchers it really was a
bit like
marvin's radar defense establishment we
are not a computing company absolutely
not
but we have developed some software that
universities might find interesting
so we're proposing for the public good
to virtually give away this software if
anybody's interested
and it it's a start and ibm won't see it
as a threat
uh so we're all right you can get hold
of this
so long as you are a bona fide degree
giving institution you can get hold of
this unix
you must have a course uh p2p11
got to keep america's balance of
payments in the black and it must be at
least a pdp 1135
not the most minimal you could get if
you do that
this unix will get you started in the
great world of
multi-user on simple terminals you can
do your own thing
you'll run out of steam after about four
or five users
but nevertheless it's all yours so we
cheerfully signed up for this and this
as i say it was back in 1979 it's all
about to happen
version seven of unix i think we did
somehow get hold of the previous one
version six but serious usage started
with version seven to find out more
about this version seven
that we were getting how did you find
out
let me be boring and oldie and say yet
again
there was no internet there were no web
pages to tell you about this
there was not even email you had to send
out
posters to departments you had to use
letters you could send faxes right
and you had to say we are the uk
unix user group principally populated by
representatives from
computer science departments in uk
universities
we all almost all of us absolutely long
to have
eunuchs we have persuaded the american
master unix user group and att
the ultimate owners of bell labs who ran
all the patents and licensing
they're going to come over and tell us
how to get licensed
for an academic use only license for
unix
and what's it all about and it was a
superb chat
shop and ideas swap shop as it were
enjoyed it hugely the star of the show
was a visitor from at
patents and licensing frank j riffle jr
i remember
his name and uh oh
boy did he have the job from hell
trying to keep everybody happy and he
said i want to license you all you're
wonderful you know
uh we love universities and i'm in
charge of patients and licensing but
i gotta warn you you must not do any
commercial usage with this
it is purely for degree giving teaching
only
right and he kept on nuttering to
himself there were a lot of gray areas
and it's my job to stamp them out and
what a heck of a job it was he said just
remember
you must be a bona fide degree giving
university institution
then you will be licensed no others
a hand goes up from the audience a guy
i got to know quite well later on but he
really was the odd man now
han goes up and said well how about me
you've licensed me for version
six but i'm not at the university where
are you from sir
and he said marcus gray this guy's name
was he said
i'm just a college i'm pre-university
you know from basically we concentrate
from 11 to 18.
i'm marlborough college i'm a public
school
now i think even the americans know that
there's nothing more
badly named than an english public
school it is
not available to the poor and the needy
as it probably should be or was
originally
no some public schools are so expensive
you need serious money to attend them
principally eaton is the most famous but
marlborough college isn't far behind i
mean
the tuition fees at marlborough college
will make your eyes water
so this guy said no no i'm not i'm
pre-university i'm marlboro college
but sir over here you know most colleges
are like
universities and marcus said no it's not
the case with me and
riffle was getting more and more ruffled
that's a joke
and said sir let me try and summarize
are you trying to tell me that you are
more or less
a very expensive version of what i would
call
a high school and marcus said sort of
said yeah that's roughly right he just
looked at mark and said sir
you should not have been licensed and he
didn't say it but in parenthesis
i could hear it going on in the
background oh boy somebody's going to be
in deep trouble
when i get back to murray hill new
jersey
he said sir you should not have been
licensed but frank j riffle is a man of
his word i will not take your license
away sir
truly it did change everything and i
do remember very well we had a lot of
conversations at the uk units group
saying
those guys at bell labs are just so good
the two of them obviously dennis and ken
we've talked about them many a time
they've invented the c
language for system implementation
they've developed unix and it does
things sensibly and this is absolutely
great
aren't we lucky i thought as a community
to have them being on our side and i did
think i wonder if they'll ever get any
recognition
from the acm which shall we say about
what they've done
and i was very pleased it took till 1983
i think
but eventually so many academics in the
u.s
and all over the world were using unix
that dennis and ken
were given the acm touring award it was
actually awarded to them in 84 it was
won and achieved in 83. so in 1984
they had to give a talk about
what their work meant and normally
when you write a paper to go with your
presentation you thank everybody which
he did
but then you go on to say here's how
units came about here's the nuts and
bolts of what it's like to really run it
we didn't get that at all we got thank
yous from ken
in cryptic terms but very heartfelt to a
lot of people so he said i now
just want to point out something to you
effectively you've got something here
where we use c as a system programming
language so the operating system is
written in a high-level language
have you any idea the problems that is
going to open up to
the potential flaws security holes let
me just demonstrate one of these to you
you'll be amazed and amused and i mean
you know what
standards we have on computer file we
don't swear
so i'll allow myself to say that one of
the
rather celebrated people that we're
going to
point you at in the next video just
described ken's contribution
as a total effing bombshell and he
wasn't wrong
a lot of people couldn't understand why
it was a bombshell but it
really really is and i'd like to do my
best
to explain to you just how
what a fundamental earthquake this
caused once people understood
what he was trying to say a few seconds
or
half a second of time then gave him a
half and then give her
a little bit and just go round and round
the people who wanted
to do some kind of computing and because
computers were even the signal is moving
in so the speed of those pulses tell us
the rate
we know which direction it is because we
know which roller it's coming from and
we can look at those